we have a quadratic factor x squared and
it's repeated see it's to the second
power so how do we solve a partial
fraction decomposition problem like this
well we're going to do is we're going to
break it up so we know it's going to be
X and this will be a because it's one
degree less plus this is going to be x
squared plus one and this is going to be
x squared plus 1 the quantity squared we
have to take into account both of these
ok the 1 to the first power and the 1 to
the second power because when we combine
these together we get a common
denominator we're not going to know if
we have this one and this one or just
this one okay so we have to take both of
those into account if it was cubed we
want to have this x squared plus 1 x
squared plus 1 squared and then the x
squared plus 1 cubed so what we have
here now is this is going to be BX plus
C notice this is one degree less and it
goes in descending order till you get to
the constant and this is going to be DX
plus e now this is a this is a big
problem these take a little bit longer
okay but we're going to do is we're
going to multiply through by the common
denominator clear the fractions so we're
going to multiply left and right sides
of this equation by the common
denominator which is this right here so
when we do that we're left with X to the
fourth plus 3x cubed plus 7x minus 1
equals a times x squared plus 1 squared
because x's are going to cancel plus BX
plus C times x times x squared plus 1
plus DX plus e times X okay so you can
see this is quite a large equation so
what we're going to do now is we're
going to be strategic we're going to
pick some values we're going to say for
example like let X equal 0 that'll
cancel out this group and this group
okay allowing us to solve for a ok so
let's see if we can do that so if we
x equals zero that's going to give us
negative one equals zero squared plus
one squared times a so a is negative one
ok good we've got that one aside from
that that's about all we're going to be
able to do to to cancel out some of
these other terms so what I'm going to
do now is I'm going to foil this out
okay I'm going to replace a with what a
equals a negative one we're going to
simplify this we're going to make a
system so I'll show you how that works
so we're going to foil this out this is
going to come out to negative x to the
fourth minus two x squared minus one
because I'm foiling this and
distributing the negative one plus this
is going to be B X let's see let's foil
this so this will be B X cubed times
this X is B X to the fourth this is
going to be let's see X and then times
the B X so that's going to be B X
squared plus CX squared times X so
that's C X cubed plus C times one times
X so that's plus C X plus DX squared
plus E X okay so now what we're going to
do is we're in a group like terms
together here okay and so the way we're
going to do that is we're going to
gather together all the X to the fourth
terms okay so if we do that we have B
minus one times X to the fourth so I
group these together we're going to get
Group two X cubed terms together now so
we've got C X cubed okay and that's the
only one so that's C X cubed we're going
to group the x squared terms together so
that's going to be this one this one and
this one so that's going to be plus
let's see that's going to be B plus D
minus two times x squared and then we're
going to group the X terms together
which that's just going to be C X and E
X so that's going to be plus C plus E
times X okay and then we have negative
one is our constant okay so we can say
this is minus one equals x to the fourth
plus 3x cubed plus 7x minus one so we're
going to solve this okay equation and
we're going to do that by setting B
minus 1 the coefficient in front of X to
the fourth term equal to this
coefficient which is 1 so we have B
minus 1 equals 1 okay so you can see B
is going to equal 2 now we're going to
set the X cubes equal to X cubes so you
can see that C equals 3 okay I equals 3
and we're going to set the coefficients
in front of the x squared terms B plus D
minus 2 and you can see there's not an x
squared term here so that's going to be
B plus D minus 2 equals 0 okay and
because we know that B is 2 that's going
to be 2 plus D minus 2 equals 0 all
those cancel so you can see that D
equals 0 and then the last one let's see
we've got C plus E which is a
coefficient in front of the X that's C
plus e equals 7 okay and we know C is 3
so that's 3 plus e equals 7 so we know
that e equals 4 and negative 1 of course
equals negative 1 so now we've got ABCD
and E we can substitute those in and
those will be our partial fractions I'll
see you in the next video